[Musique]
les faits peur
n'a pas idée de mettre des trucs pareils
là devant la
pardon
c'est tombé à pas vous voyez ça je sais
pas la vôtre oui voyez bien je tombais
un conte cali c'est carton là devant
chez vous
voilà qu'est ce que je disais
de foot
c'est moi
non mais on s'est alors
couché sinon ça marche pas
enfin des accouchements par an mais
c'est quoi j'en rigole ou quoi on fait
une connerie ou réparer ces ou premier
c'est ça ramasser les cartes
je peux partir donc si vous avez
l'autorisation au moins de mettre les
trucs devant là et bien sûr une position
partout on est sympa ou alors
vous allez me faire une attestation
comme quoi j'ai eu un accident à cela
c'est ça qui doit encore
passer car ne portait pas quand vous
avez pas ne voulais pas me rendre là je
fasse avant de planter mon truc vous
m'aidez ramasser les cartes c'est tout
point barre façon d'appeler les îlots si
j'ai un mot du docteur j'vais pas loin
de la ligne b c'est
possible que vous faites a pâti de la
sacu monter ça pour toucher une
assurance et ça
moi j'ai une tête à celui je m'en fous
j'ai un casque
à casque
tgp on se demandait pas grand chose là
dedans après je suis
allé chez vous et elle m'appelait pas
l'afrique
alors puisque moi l'attestation
mais vous allez la faire vous
l'attestation donc quand vous êtes
d'accord pour passer à la télé pour la
caméra cachée
[Musique]